had you guys been talking to marvel
about stuff prior to moon night like how
did this all happen for you guys yeah
yeah we'd actually we've gone into
marvel
over and over and over and uh you know
and and uh and we've been trying to find
something to work on together and they
very genuinely would say the same thing
every time it's like we've got to find
something
um and this one came
around i think november
of 2020 we were actually we pitched on
this while we were working on this
netflix show called archive 81
and we actually had to ask for time away
from the production to pitch for this
and they're like we understand you
should do that
[Laughter]
um but also under full covert lockdown
you know where where and it was like
deep deep full covered lockdown where we
were in hotel rooms or on set and that
was it
um that was how we celebrated getting
this you know we gave ran to each
other's room big old hug and everything
like that we're like wish we could go
out to eat
it was also kind of surreal
from a point of view of when i was
really like when i was like eight years
old or something i got my first
fascination with comic books and i
remember like trying to share that with
my schoolmates
and i remember them looking at me like i
had walked into the coolest punk rock
store in the world and asked for green
day you know there's like no no no
whatever you're reading don't read that
moon night is the cool thing and i can
and so i always had this memory being
eight years old having that communicated
to me and then us getting the job to do
it i was like oh we got the cool thing
like this is the cool superhero
uh i'm so curious uh obviously this is
your first big marvel thing what ended
up surprising you about working with
them that perhaps you weren't expecting
going in well i think everyone has this
idea of a bit of a monolithic um
structure to marvel you know where
people would would question like as
independent filmmakers were going to
feel shackled or something like that
and honestly
it was just so incredibly collaborative
and i think that was the big surprise we
we knew that they would be collaborative
we know that they're a very best idea
wins kind of company um but we didn't
quite realize just how much freedom we
would have uh and so and not just the
two of us but but everybody i mean
um oscar and ethan and may
had so much of a hand in the story that
we're telling not just as performers but
as as writers as you know as
storytellers
um and i think that was
you know there was always a bit of a
like can we do that exactly can we be
can we be that strange or go that far
off the rails or or um
actually even seeing one division you
know we didn't actually know that they
would commit to
that crazy format you know that that you
know they're what you would think their
target audience hasn't even probably
even seen a black and white sitcom but
they did it they just committed to it
fully
and uh that was that was really cool to
find out how bold they were willing to
be as long as we were the ones pushing
it forward not just two of us i mean we
all the collaborators on the project
one of the things about marvel and i
think the reason why people love marvel
is that every time they make something
they just reinvent what the superhero
genre can do and that's why there's no
like fatigue if you will with marvel
properties can you sort of talk about
that aspect
yeah i mean
with with moon knight specifically
there's an obvious thing of like there's
no reason to do moon night unless you're
going to be bold that character
specifically
but beyond all of that we always felt
like if we weren't
if we weren't being bold if we weren't
going left of center if we weren't
taking big swings
that
that
that we were we were missing the mark of
what this universe wants from us missing
the mark
oh i i'm curious how did you guys end up
doing episodes two and four we were
almost gonna do like three and five like
how did that get figured out
no actually you know what's funny it was
deep after we like we were already um
deep in the production when we talked to
muhammad we're like why do we have two
and four we were just presented with two
and four and honestly the answer is very
very boring there was like kind of
logistical calendar reasons and all of
that um and because have you seen the
episodes
okay and so you know without without
giving things away for people who
haven't but um four is in many ways
location wise it's very much its own
thing you know and so it was able to be
something that we were able to cordon
off a little bit episodes one and two
talk to each other a little bit more but
um but that was kind of as we were
figuring out the production
um and again you'll see with five and
six uh again very much their own voice
from each from each other and from the
rest of the episodes so that was pretty
much why is that um that each episode
has its own voice and we were handed two
and four
do you think it's do you think moonlight
has obviously never been done in live
action before like this is the first
time he's being brought into the mcu do
you feel like that's easier or harder
when a character like this you know when
you sort of have free reign to create
you know you know
it it's not that it's easier or harder
in terms of
telling the story you want to tell with
this character what what does come with
it that's a little bit difficult is that
it's the pressure to get it right i
suppose is a little higher because it
hasn't been done yet and also with a
character that is
that is rightfully so as beloved as moon
knight and beloved for being something
different and
that comes with its its own set of
pressures you just want to make sure you
get it right but in terms of
of of telling a story using a character
that doesn't have a live-action
pre-established mythology that was
actually it was easier in some ways
and also
50 years of great comic books to draw
from
inspiration if nothing else it could be
as simple as like just a piece of
artwork we loved from one that would
inspire a whole shot um
[Music]
but uh
but yeah i mean it was if any i guess in
some ways it was a little bit
easier him not having a live action
pre-established anything yeah i mean
you've seen all of our all i think all
of our independent features all of those
share a universe so the idea of working
within a shared universe comes weirdly
second nature to us
but um
but really it was it was way just more
exciting i think just just very very
exciting that that
that there were no
boundaries to what he had to be you know
nowhere where he had to fit
also
oh sorry i also say also having these
not only just i mean everyone knows that
oscar isaac and ethan hawk are some of
the greatest actors of our generation um
but
they are also
great novelists and filmmakers and
screenwriters and to to be in a
situation where they could take some
sort of personal authorship over the
creation of these live-action characters
well i mean that's you got you got two
of the best we've got right now doing
that and so that that was exciting
uh before i run into time with you since
we're talking marvel i might as well
bring up loki um how did you guys uh
hook up for that
um
i mean we're still kind of even
processing uh being being handed
that job you know um but i suppose uh
you know what we can say about it um is
that uh we're really really proud of
what we've done on moon night and i
think that uh that marvel really likes
what we're able to do on moon night and
so we're hoping to kind of take all the
lessons that we learned which are
infinite
you know the
unbelievable amount of of uh of life
experience and and craft and art that we
uh that we made in moon knight and we
want to take all of that and kind of
bundle it back together um as we leave
loki
also it's also nice to be tackling
another character
in the mcu who is defined by
by being
um being different than the rest of the
pack and another outcast yeah they all
have complexity but but these two have
complexity and being outcasts and
there's something about that that feels
very special and an honor to tackle
cool thank you so much and seriously
congrats thank you it's good seeing a
familiar face today
you